hey youtubers is Charlie so a brand new
series 8 trailer just dropped and
revealed an old enemy Davros is back
he's gonna be one of the main villains
in series 8 I say one of the main
villains just because if one big villain
is coming back it doesn't mean they're
the only villain that's coming back so
this is gonna be a breakdown of the new
footage in my top 5 theories about how
he could come back hello to any new
people if you're just finding me for the
first time I'm doing weekly Doctor Who
videos until series 8 gets here then I'm
doing a whole bunch of stuff be sure to
subscribe to get it I'm even gonna be
doing a special giveaway whenever the
episodes start airing so let's start
with the actual footage what they've
done in the last couple of teasers is
used the same scene from different
perspectives the TARDIS console erupting
in sparks in the previous clips he was
just standing in a different position
but in this trailer he's standing at the
console operating it
it's footage taken from the same scene
it's just a different moment inside that
scene the really interesting part comes
after the first explosion if you don't
recognize the voice
it's Davros I had to listen to it twice
just because the first time my volume
was turned down and it sounded like a
Dalek Daleks have been confirmed for
series 8 we just don't know quite how
they're gonna appear the second time I
watched the clip the voice sounded way
too human to be a normal Dalek it's not
quite high-pitched enough so then I
actually just listened to a couple of
different versions of Davros his voice
here's what the voice in the trailer
sounds like and then here is what Davros
his voice sounded like during stolen
Earth in series 4 so yes Davros is back
we'll talk about the mechanics of how
that's happening in just a second first
let's talk about what he's saying to the
doctor in the clip I see into your soul
I see Beauty divinity hatred as he's
saying these things
it looks like he's scanning the doctor
as if he's inside the TARDIS with him I
don't think that's the case I think
Davros is voice sounds so dreamlike I'm
wondering if it's coming from some sort
of another space like the Medusa cascade
like it's coming through that rift like
when we heard the Time Lords voices
coming through the cracks in the
universe in the 50th anniversary special
he just sounds like he's coming from
somewhere really far away plus the scan
zooms in on the doctors hearts in his
heartbeats I think a couple of things
are going on here
I don't think Davos is gonna try and
steal the doctors body parts or anything
like that I think he's stuck somewhere
outside normal space like outside the
universe like he's going to play on the
doctors new personality to help him
return so how is he still alive
well his final fate was never confirmed
during journey's end in that episode the
meta-crisis doctor and Donna were able
to destroy the new Daleks and left
Davros on the crucible which was on fire
he himself had been enslaved by the
supreme Dalek and the new Daleks and
forced to create that reality bomb as
the doctor left with Donna he offered to
save Davros Devers declined and cursed
the doctor calling him the destroyer of
worlds
it was an interesting twist on the
character since Davros had been such a
villain over the years to be fair he did
kind of start out as more of a misguided
bad scientist not a straight-up monster
villain although he did turn into a
monster over time so it's pretty clear
from this clip that he survived and
somehow used the Medusa cascade to
survive supposedly the doctor sealed it
in journey's end but my guess is that
the events of the 50th anniversary and
the cracks of the universe allowed
Davros to send messages out that
dreamlike quality of his voice makes it
sound like he's still stuck in there
like his voice is being picked up
through a transmission in the TARDIS you
have to remember that the Daleks base
did contain enough energy to destroy the
TARDIS whenever his defenses were down
and it's possible that in the events of
the Christmas special in the
regeneration that the TARDIS defenses
did come down and Davros use that moment
to attack that could be why the TARDIS
is exploding or it could be some other
reason so in case you haven't seen any
of the episodes of Doctor Who that
involved the Medusa cascade it's
essentially a rift in space and time the
Daleks were going to use Davros as
reality bomb to cause an explosion that
would travel from the rift into normal
space across all universes remember your
multiverse Theory the Daleks are trying
to make it so that they would be the
only race to survive in all of existence
across all the universes so here are my
top five theories about how Davros could
be coming back in series 8 number 5
he could have already used the cracks in
the universe to return and has been
rebuilding his power somewhere quietly
since the 50th anniversary number 4 it
will involve the Dalek Caan prophecy
Steven Moffat could reinterpret the
prophecy and use it in a new way
Davros is speech during journeys and
talked about looking into the doctors
soul that was
happening while Dalek Caan was secretly
manipulating events to help bring about
the destruction of the Daleks number
three he used a mechanical solution he
simply rebuilt part of the crucible and
used that to get out number two
Davros formed an alliance with a
character that we haven't met yet and
used them to get out and my number one
theory about how Davros is coming back
he's still stuck inside the Medusa
cascade and he's going to play on the
doctors new personality to try and help
him get out or tricking the new doctor
into helping him get out the master was
able to trick the doctor using the
pocket watch so if he can trick the
doctor so can Davros so Peter Capaldi
was actually just seen on set filming
the final episodes of series eight not
the Christmas special just the final
actual episodes it featured a character
called the gatekeeper a new character
and loads of Cybermen someone even
spotted the head of a classic Mondas
Cybermen on the ground so it's possible
that Davros could return right before or
during the finale and the doctor will
get the help of this new character and
the Cybermen to help defeat him it's
just that it doesn't look like that
doctor is a captive of the Cybermen in
these pictures that's why I think that
they're helping him it could be a
situation like the enemy of my enemy is
my friend
the Daleks and the Cybermen have worked
together in the past but they're not
friendly races and Davros is own Dalek
creations even betrayed him during
series 4 so alliances change all the
time so it's not too far-fetched to
believe that the Cybermen could forge an
alliance with the doctor but now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
below how do you think the Davros is
going to return and do you think that
the Dalek Caan prophecy is going to come
back so like I said I'll be doing weekly
bonus Doctor Who videos until series 8
gets here be sure to subscribe to get
everything
episode 1 is going to premiere August
23rd so mark your calendars and in case
you're way behind I've been doing tons
of bonus videos for series 8 so far you
can actually click here to get a break
down to the last trailer and click here
to learn all about the episodes in
series 8 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you